bonsoir à tous comment allez-vous
c'est vraiment une un plaisir une joie
pour moi d'être ici de voir autant de
monde
c'est vraiment ça fait ça fait chaud au
cœur de pouvoir voir vos visages
j'espère que vous êtes content également
d'être là
ok je suis pas le seul alors
notre sujet aujourd'hui c'est la
réussite
et quand on parle de la réussite il y a
un sujet un thème sur lequel on peut
tous se mettre d'accord
on peut même peut-être y avoir une animé
entre nous
c'est que la réussite
n'arrive jamais par accident
n'arrive pas par hasard
si vous pensez le contraire vous avez le
temps
la réussite est un phénomène
multifactoriel il y a plusieurs choses
qui jouent dans la réussite c'est sûr
mais pour moi il y a deux piliers il y a
deux choses qui sont fondamentales pour
moi pour la réussite
la première chose c'est une très bonne
préparation il faut se préparer
et la deuxième chose c'est le travail
ardu cravacher donc ça pour moi ce sont
les deux piliers pour la réussite
et donc quand on parle de réussite
j'aime beaucoup cette citation de
Sénèque c'est Monsieur philosophe
préféré et il a dit il n'y a pas de vent
favorable pour un bateau qui n'a pas de
cap ou qui n'a pas de direction
qu'est-ce que ce n'est que voulait dire
il voulait tout simplement dire qu'il
n'y a pas de réussite sans avoir une
direction sans avoir des objectifs
définis vous devez savoir où vous allez
c'est ça le message principal de Sénèque
ma mère aurait dit il faut avoir des
objectifs qui sont clairs net et précis
ma mère est très sale et très sage
et donc je voulais vous poser une
question
qui parmi vous a entendu parler de la
Harvard Business School lever la main je
vois vos mains
ok peut-être d'ailleurs que certains de
vous iront à avoir un jour
c'est possible
donc en 1979
il y a des chercheurs qui ont qui sont à
l'arbre pour faire une étude
1979 beaucoup d'entre vous n'étaient pas
nés la majorité même donc ils sont à la
Harvard pour faire une étude et ils ont
interrogé mille étudiants
et à ses ennemis l'étudiants ils ont
posé deux questions
la première question qui leur ont posé
c'est est-ce que vous avez une vision
pour votre futur est-ce que vous savez
ce que vous voulez faire dans le futur
la deuxième question qui leur ont posé
c'est est-ce que cette vision est écrite
sur le papier est-ce que c'est possible
de voir quelque part
alors à la première question 13% des
étudiants ont répondu qu'ils avaient une
vision approximative de leur futur
à la deuxième question
3% des étudiants ont répondu que cette
vidéo ces objectifs étaient écrits sur
le papier
alors moi je suis un homme de lettres
je suis pas très très bon en maths mais
si je me trompe pas 3% de 1000 ça fait
30 étudiants est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord
si je me suis trompé soufflez-moi à la
bonne réponse 30 étudiants ok donc il y
a 30 étudiants sur 1000 qui avait des
objectifs écrits
10 ans plus tard en 1989
ces chercheurs ont repris l'étude ils
ont réinterrogé ces 1000 maintenant
anciens étudiants
et cette fois-ci ils vont reposer une
seule question il leur ont demandé quel
est le montant de votre patrimoine ou
combien d'argent avez-vous accumulé ces
10 dernières années
alors vous pouvez imaginer
le résultat de cela et qu'est-ce que
c'est chercheur en découvert en
analysant les données ils ont découvert
que
les 30 étudiants qui avaient des
objectifs définis 10 ans plus tôt
avait des revenus tenez-vous bien
10 fois supérieur au 97%. j'ai dit 10
fois c'est considérable
alors certains d'entre vous vont me dire
oui mais Bruno l'argent c'est pas tout
l'argent n'est pas le seul moyen de
mesurer ou de définir le succès et ceux
d'entre vous qui pensent je suis
d'accord avec vous vraiment je suis
d'accord
c'est pour cela que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
apprendre de cette étude c'est pas juste
qui gagnait plus d'argent ce qui est un
fait mais je veux que vous voyez le
résultat de cette étude comme
c'est 30 étudiants ont accompli plus de
choses que les autres ils ont parcouru
une distance plus grande que les autres
si c'était des athlètes on dirait que
ces athlètes ont plus performer que les
autres parce qu'ils avaient des
objectifs qui étaient clairs et qui
étaient définis
et donc que pensez-vous que ce soit mes
objectifs moi j'ai deux objectifs très
précis pour aujourd'hui ils sont définis
évidemment vous pouvez imaginer par mon
discours premier objectif c'est que vous
vous écriviez vos objectifs et votre
vision
c'est l'objectif de mon pitch ce soir
et mon deuxième objectif c'est que
avarde ils ont fait trois pour cent
soyons fous Neoma 30% 10 fois plus donc
je veux que 30 % d'entre vous vous
écriviez vos objectifs au moins
si c'est plus c'est génial
et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai apporté
cet objet
je sais pas si vous arrivez à avoir ici
j'ai deux stylos quand j'étais gamin on
appelait ça des stylos bics ce sont des
stylos à billes j'ai un rouge et un bleu
quand j'étais gamin ma mère m'a acheté
10 de chaque couleur pour la rentrée
scolaire après tu les perds tu les
casses
et donc moi je suis quelqu'un je suis
comme vous je suis très connecté j'ai
trois téléphones portables parce que
j'ai un téléphone pour le boulot j'ai
des tablettes touch j'ai un Chromebook
et j'ai deux autres ordinateurs donc je
suis exactement comme vous et c'est
difficile de me retirer mon portable
demain mais je suis convaincu et je
crois vraiment qu'il y a un mystère
derrière le fait d'écrire ces objectifs
alors vous allez me dire mais pourquoi
tu peux nous expliquer ça j'ai pas
vraiment d'explication rationnelle à
vous à vous dire mais je vais vous
donner un exemple
tous les moments importants de la vie
ont les signes avec un stylo
le jour où vous allez vous marier vous
signez l'acte de mariage
le jour vous allez acheter une maison
vous allez acheter une maison vous allez
signer l'acte d'achat quand vous allez à
la banque pour faire un prêt vous signez
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire je m'engage je prends la
responsabilité j'accepte les conditions
et je suis convaincu et c'est une
théorie vraiment personnelle je suis
convaincu que quand on est cri ces
objectifs c'est un engagement comprend
avec soi-même on dit je m'engage à faire
ce que je suis en train d'écrire donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
crois au fond de mon cœur donc je
souhaite vraiment que vous écriviez vos
objectifs pas en début d'année
pas la semaine prochaine mais je veux
que vous commenciez ce soir pas
maintenant mais ce soir
donc c'est ça le ma mission de la soirée
et c'est vrai que quand on parle
d'objectifs d'écrire ses objectifs j'ai
un ami qui est un garçon brillant très
intelligent il a fait science pour mais
sans problème c'est que à chaque fois
qu'il a un objectif à chaque fois qu'il
a une idée
il la met dans une espèce de
centrifugeuse
comment on pourrait dire à probabilité
alors il va essayer de trouver toutes
les raisons possibles et imaginables
pourquoi ça ne marchera pas tous les
obstacles toutes les difficultés il va
les amplifier et il va finir par ne
jamais rien faire ou remettre à demain
ça s'appelle la procrastination
et donc j'ai de nombreuses conversations
avec lui
et un jour durant une de nombreuses
conversations
son épouse a pris le téléphone pour pas
aller avec moi et elle m'a dit bonjour
Bruno je vais te remercier
j'ai dit merci pourquoi elle me dit tu
sais souvent j'écoute vos conversations
je passe et j'entends les choses que
vous vous dites ou les choses que tu lui
dis et tu sais moi je suis mère au foyer
je suis une femme au foyer et j'ai
toujours voulu créer une entreprise
et un jour pendant que je passais tu
étais en train de lui dire d'écrire ses
objectifs
et je me suis dit pourquoi moi je le
ferais pas et j'ai écrit mes objectifs
et je veux te dire que j'ai créé ma
société dans le domaine du tourisme
c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu faire
c'est une petite société mais je
commence à être connu on m'invite à des
séminaires à des forums dans le domaine
du tourisme et donc je voulais te dire
merci
évidemment moi j'ai essayé de d'aider
mon ami j'ai fini par aider sa femme ce
qui est génial qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait
elle a écrit
et ensuite elle a mis la machine en
action
donc ce soir mon message il est très
simple ce que je veux vous dire c'est
votre votre futur votre réussite et
votre succès littéralement tiens dans
vos mains
et je veux que vous rappeler une simple
idée de tout ce que j'ai dit ce soir
c'est que tu deviens et je m'adresse
directement à chacun d'entre vous je
vous regarde tu deviens ce que tu écris
alors écrit